this week we've got emoji plates kind
Chappell and banana plug conscience all
first I knew it banana plug no we're
doing emoji what was it
plate plate plate emoji Chappell you
could put emojis on your Chapelle plates
every weekend scramble some 80 year old
man's clicked in this video and he's
like I have no idea t through his
computer at the window
did he have the big monitors he had the
one that you could buy for $500 at
Circuit City any paid $2 for insurance
yeah [ __ ] love those guys and he paid
another $150 for and the antivirus
package there's a 300 megabyte hard
drive oh but that used to be the move
man that [ __ ] was this [ __ ] you can
still go to Best Buy and get ripped off
though for sure all vs. yeah don't even
worry about it okay so this story here
oh yeah emoji please
so the Australian state of Queensland
Queensland you're right
thanks Linda Queensland they said they
are they announced that they will soon
be allowing drivers to have sleep lucky
jeez on them it's so weird the Bears for
[ __ ] shirt how do you [ __ ] report
that you can't take all of you much Mike
it's the call with the heart and its
eyes you know it's like it's a Kate kfb
r39 and then a [ __ ] bear emoji wait I
like your Australian accent I don't know
it's Australian Irish you're a bein let
me work on it that's the problem why do
you have to look down every time you're
doing it I'm trying to visualize the
it's a poor orphan trying to sell
newspapers able to pick out of all the
emoji options it's only five emoji yeah
everyone to use the eggplant one and the
peach for sure actually you mentioned
both of those in this article speech
people want that's what I was looking
for thank you the five options is faced
with tears of joy or better known as the
crying laughing emoji sunglasses emoji
winking emoji smiling emoji and heart
eyes emoji so no explore before laughing
at me while I'm in traffic with that one
there crying laughing one yeah well I
mean they're saying that it's just a
natural progression of society to
eventually have emoji plate anyway more
characters anyway
we need more characters any dude I just
read a story that police are now having
to use they're having to analyze emojis
to solve like merge okay pretty
interesting stuff we're we're because
now that emojis are in our society like
you have to think about where that
applies now it's like going through I'm
an emotional as book cuz I've never used
it I do the thumbs up okay
not the face at least you're not like
Bart and he uses it and it comes off
very flirty with people oh he's always
like you being all Winky and [ __ ] in
like dude she's literacy ends every
sentence with the I heard from a guy a
single dude that he said that it's if
you're a girl and you send emojis guys
automatically think you're flirting with
them it's true oh [ __ ] I said
Mogi every time but guys want every girl
to be flirting with them so I can
especially single guys so it's like
they're just looking for any sign
exactly he's mining it sure cuz
sometimes I'll be I'll send a really
angry emoji like the ready face to KC
cuz he did some [ __ ] and then she'll
write back like lol or something you use
emojis in earnest yeah I've never met
one of you I've only met irony you just
cut Matt for emojis why this is like Kay
you cut like crazy and you put the red
face anything from messing around
yeah I'm cutting you [ __ ] little dick
[ __ ] my hatred it's also something
that you could do like in an Internet
comment you can write you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I [ __ ] hate you
I hate your family and I hate your
religion whatever it may be and then at
the end if you put like a little winky
thing with the smiley it changes it yeah
thank you that red face emoji you take
me serious it's for real
but if you put in the emoji it makes it
cute you should send him [ __ ] leather
face with a sob yeah or something yeah I
mean you gotta get that's still pretty
cute it's a little cute yeah I think if
you sent a picture with his car and a
lighter that looks that's more serious
there you go don't smile you bash his
windows and take a picture of that
that's that's when you're serious it's
wrong piece for it maybe just the
lighter in front of the car there's no
damage there moving on to the next story
Dave Chappelle we get skipped that one
yes give it nobody cares about it's
already all it's already like seven
minutes all I like Dave Chappelle but
nobody appreciates him the way I do
you think you're the only person that
appreciates it come on
he is nobody but people in this room
I love gutters like oh [ __ ] teacher
calls but know how a world exists were
the last six of his fans
I agree nobody says it enough yeah
but yeah so do Chappelle he's such a
nice guy he can deliver tickets to this
couple that got scammed on Craigslist
because they were trying to buy tickets
to Dave Chappelle's Show oh my god and
so it was about they spent about 500
bucks on four tickets and the scammer
obviously you know stopped responding
and then so this made it to the local
news but they they were kept anonymous
because they were just really
embarrassed that that happened to them
yes so Dave Chappelle's team saw that or
he saw that and so they reached out to
the news station to try to get in
contact with that couple and so he
decided to hand-deliver the tickets to
his show and surprise them so much show
you guys a video cool MacDonnell's
know they got napkins there that's not
McDonald I want to get scanned on
Craigslist so he could hand deliver some
tickets to oh we should do a hoax oh
don't get caught though I've seen some
pretty good hoaxes lately recently yeah
why are you crying
because I'm thinking about all the
hoaxes
[Laughter]
oh my god that's dough why is he looking
like a delivery guy her security like he
was just bouncing on the outside mm-hmm
you see a happy Valentine's Day because
they're performing I want to buy tickets
to Maisy Shanna Hart doesn't do that no
care part does not do that he just
cheats on his wife what do you guys have
against Kevin Hart
Charlotte yesterday Chappelle in his
early talks about she's so sout yeah
because his own son likes Kevin Hart
even more yeah so this happened in North
Carolina Charlotte North Carolina
and yeah so Dave Chappelle is just
saying like you know this is something
easy for me to do like it's not a big
deal like if I could make there okay
I'll tell you something great that I'm
doing so one of our fans here ina Lee we
got oh that's a try and really I mean
this whole thing I don't like to
televise my charity because I feel like
in it's an authentic but I have to
[ __ ] one-up Dave Chappelle here
because he's not the only good person in
this one Helen that one of our fans got
there shady agents package stolen so
some [ __ ] cook out there is playing
shady agents with all of his crook buddy
shady agent Proctor shady agents right
and he even got the [ __ ] VIP one the
black one the limited-edition one yeah
so I'm gonna give him his very own
oh you haven't done it yet I just found
out a week ago
stop the presses for this leave Chappell
Chappell already did it and he did it on
Valentine's Day which is like a week and
a half you know what I'm gonna do
well first when I get rich well I'm
gonna go to each one of my fans house
and I'm gonna deliver them a bar of gold
oh my god you're only the ones that are
not cyberbullying people you're
incredible
you don't even know what you're doing
because they don't even deserve that
this guy deserve it deserves it cuz he
no [ __ ] that
bear to get free entertainment no she's
better than you I'm sorry no that's a
way better cell dude Islander idea
because yours is impossible to do I'm
Google bars if I should get rich she
could get rid thank you are you saying
women can't get rid rich therefore he
hates women hey women I just said Nikki
so so just half Filipino half white
women oh oh I didn't realize you're
racist - okay that worked for white
onion yep so Dave Chappelle he is
awesome yeah so if you're Dave Chappelle
no no no Joe's awesome gold bars
everybody go subscribe mmm what if Dave
Chappelle went there and he's and he
does exactly what just did and then he's
like okay it's 500 bucks no but then
everyone's like haha you know everyone's
like he's a comedian things like no
where's my [ __ ] money it's far but if
he was the one that scammed um there you
go he's a nice guy better than Kevin
Hart yeah you can't trust celebrities
now but that's what's interesting about
being a comedian is you if you if you
even just say something serious everyone
laugh so what you just said yeah because
everyone loves you even laughs at your
[ __ ] that's like you every time you say
something real people think you're just
trolling I love it I say something real
people think I'm joking yeah yeah the
three of you guys think it's a
double-edged sword cuz I actually opened
up my heart to her mom recently and she
was like she didn't believe me what yeah
I was like we're in the car
well the real star in the car and then I
were just driving around to grab this
thing this thing called Chronicles of
sleeping baby we're in titles like
sleeping we just drive around let him
sleep in the car Random House is all I
do you like this house you like that
house whatever and I was telling her I
was like hey like this is one of the
reasons why or she actually brought up
her mom was in the car so she was like
this is one of the reasons why Bart
really enjoys you hanging out with us
because he didn't have family growing up
so I was like yeah you know when I was
six my parents got divorced I'm the only
child so I don't have brothers or
sisters so I'm just at home by myself
all the time and so when I see tyka half
grandparents come and visit him I want
to look on the nest and I see Gio like
playing with them I seen all this family
stuff it makes me feel really good and
I'm like getting choked up about it and
then it didn't sound like he was getting
turned up I was you talking about and
then the mom was like mmhmm that's not
what she said she was just like she went
she's like man I'd like to believe you
but you messed with me so much I never
know what's a joke or not she's just
like I'm ready for the other get the
punchline now come on you mess around
with me so much I never know when you're
telling the truth and I'm like you
created that no but but so when you
traumatize are doing if I'm doing bit
though none of those are facts it's
outrageous what was the bit though were
you like hey hug any like [ __ ] way
there's no bit here it's all facts right
so it's it's her own inability to see
the difference between the two and but I
get I get what's the typical bit oh no
no no it's not the inability of that
it's just that just means you guys don't
communicate enough to what she knows she
knows enough of your backstory to know
was bitter and off I'm trying to give
her backstory what's she been duped on
before that she's like everything dude
everything there's so much you can't
even think of it
like you give her Christmas presents
full of dog [ __ ] or something
I don't even know and put it in the
Tiffany's box
it's like daily like multiple times I
pay so that's why there's someone I
can't even think of anything it's so
normal now oh yeah well you created that
the double-edged sword being a comedian
I tell you that my damn Rory 18 year
olds from UC Santa Cruz got cut with his
drug-dealing app so you created an app
and at brawl that's genius
that's genius what is it called banana
plug banana plug that's amazing that's a
great [ __ ] name - yeah kids a jinx
they're their mascots the banana slug
yeah why they swear they put blood
because the plug is the drug dealer
yeah like the hook-up that's how much I
do drugs but yeah so this kid here he
even posted up like posters around this
you [ __ ] Modi he got too cocky
yeah and then so he was saying like you
know if you use this app you can make
special requests oh god and he was
selling how did he get caught did he put
his own name we traced back to IP of
because a UC Santa Cruz police officer
noticed the app advertising around the
campus and then they contacted Homeland
Security oh [ __ ]
and then that's when undercover officers
communicated with him to go bestial
things and so wait so he was the the app
owner and a dealer that's what he [ __ ]
up what did idiot that's where he [ __ ]
up you should have just made the app and
bounced he should have been like the
eBay of [ __ ] drug it should have been
referral only yeah you get up you get a
percentage and then let the other drug
dealers get caught for that call it oh
you're smart
smart guy Colin created this guy he
looks like he does a lot of weed yeah he
was selling like shrooms and Molly and
cocaine and like everything whoa so he
made a app just for his drug dealing
I mean either way we it's this is his
[ __ ] name
why did you need the FBI and all
[ __ ] stupid oh they had to prove that
he was actually selling drugs yeah
that's a prove it again look let's get
homeland security to investigate and
their names right there yeah who neither
detective for that [ __ ] I don't know
it's just I thought it was pretty funny
the local cops couldn't do it true yeah
I don't know I guess the idea was bigger
consequences than literally that's the
protocol I think yeah I also just like
to say yeah that's just protocol well
you're white so ability with Colin Riley
Howard yeah so he now faces up to 20
years in prison and fined the $1,000,000
for each of the two alleged violations
he he could have coded a different app
and made a bunch of money first and then
made it better yeah that's what Joe was
saying he just takes common people yeah
oh do you sell shrooms cocaine no I'm
saying he's smart enough to code an app
that's pretty cool that that he's like
young all these kids are learning how to
do all these as you said that maybe I
heard all the [ __ ] trolls are not
going home it's so easy oh [ __ ] they
probably all know how to do that and I
just I just heard the [ __ ] comment I
don't think they do I think it's [ __ ]
hard still yeah oh yeah do you think
they have templates kinda like website
yeah I bet they do I bet they actually
aetherium aetherium crypto if cerium is
like that I know all these that's build
over top of aetherium that's how it
works it's like when we were kids and
the adults were like what's a CDO or
what's your website one time I told my
mom about mp3s I was like yeah you can
download any song you want to off the
internet and you play it on this little
thing that it plays the songs and she's
like no get a song off of the Internet
and she's like that well how would they
make money and I'm like I don't know but
you could my friend did it and she's
like no and she like flat-out refused
until she actually saw an mp3 player how
did you go like this to your mom this
was in - this was in 1999 were you like
you're so wrong dude when I was in
middle school some more thing I would
mean where I was I had just read this
thing about how the president has what
they called the nuclear football which
is a suitcase that has all of our
nuclear codes in it so that he and he
has it with him at all times so that he
can launch
he just are so wherever the [ __ ] at any
point right and I was telling my buddy
that and he's like that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] and then and then the next day
he's like I talked to my dad last night
my dad said that's [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I'm like dude it's in [ __ ] Newsweek
you idiot you can read it mm-hmm but his
own dad like and he went he had a mullet
he was a [ __ ] idiot that's the
smartest person in the world to him to
that kid you know he tells his [ __ ]
hick idiot probably with a beard like
that sounds like [ __ ] [ __ ] right
exactly
I mean at Toad species yeah and then
that kid gets a grow up just in
ignorance yes is that they find out
later and they're like oh [ __ ] my
parents didn't know anything hopefully
then hopefully hopefully they realized
soon
[Music]